hi this is Matt Welch for a reason TV
I'm out in front of mile high stadium as
a Barack Obama calls it i think it's
called invesco field now and as you can
see in the background but we're going to
continue to show you as the camera
leaves my aviator sunglasses an
extraordinary sight here it's 240 in the
afternoon the line not only snakes
around and through the other side of the
stadium and passed and under a bridge
but around to the dennys where we spent
forty dollars on parking and this is
only one of many lines waiting to see
Barack Obama this afternoon for speech
that's not going to even begin for
another five and a half hours here
reason of course we are here to put to
rain on the parade just a little bit and
talk about some of the issues that
people aren't going to hear after
they've waited in line in the Sun and
listen to Jon Bon Jovi at all I was at
the democratic convention in two
thousand where there was incredible
interest not in the 80,000 level but
more than 1000 2000 level for what was
then called the shadow convention as
Arianna Huffington was about halfway
between her great Traverse from right to
left she held an alternative convention
to talk about things that we're not
going to be talked about at the regular
convention specifically issues like
assaults on civil liberties under a bill
clinton era and the drug war which has
imprisoned just incredible amounts of
people and been impacted poor minority
communities in a devastating way there
were several protests of people talking
about the federalization of cops the
militarization of police force and other
Fourth Amendment things you're not going
to hear that at all at this convention
Dave Weigel has been talking to some
people here some delegates who share
those concerns that were brought up
eight years ago but are they talking
about at this time if you if you pride
delegate he will talk about this sort of
thing I chatted with delegates all week
but especially today about the drug war
and about civil liberties and about
immigration again and because they're
going they're kind of off the agenda
it's all energy and how McCain is a bush
clone and their pet
about it they what a I hear that people
went to the criminalisation I talked to
elected elected officials were former
life officials who want
decriminalization for example but they
either don't want to worry about it
because they want to win first or they
have a sort of I guess you'd call it an
audacious hope that Barack Obama because
he's a nice guy who agrees with them is
going to make all this stuff happen and
it's I didn't pay this much attention in
1992 but i'm sure this this is kind of
what it was like we got a democrat
coming in forget about that other stuff
pipe down it's going to get better when
you actually look at the democratic
platform there are certain words you
will not see marijuana is one drug war
is a phrase that doesn't come up crack
cocaine some other things that were of
interest to people you will see talk
about immigration there but it's a sort
of confused talk one that wants to go
after employee sanctions Mike Flynn was
at an immigration event this morning
what do you see about the sort of civil
libertarian aspects of the Democrats
approach to immigration this time around
well it's interesting I mean there's a
clear divide I mean the elected
officials and party regulars I spoke to
have very strict talking points and it's
comprehensive reform secure the borders
sanction employers and Obama the
Democrats are going to be awesome the
activists I talked to are very leery you
can you can see the sense they're very
suspicious but they are just hopeful
that Obama will do the right thing and
they see it it's a civil liberties issue
and a human rights issue the way we do
and they're willing to just kind of cast
their lot and hope it'll work out and
then at the end of the day they just
said well we'll just march a lot more
but they're also supporting things like
Real ID Act and even a verified to some
degree where Americans who aren't
immigrants are going to have to
basically prove their own identity to a
federal database that's right in fact
the former mayor of Denver federico pena
told me how we have to have a real ID
and we have to have secure identity
papers to so we can move forward on
comprehensive reform so you know again
the eight years of the Bush
administration has just caused them to
throw off all these things they used to
like and agree with and just throw their
laden with Obama some of the aspects of
Fourth Amendment's assaults in the drug
war and these things were perpetrated
especially by New Democrats the sort of
Clinton era tough on crime wave of death
penalty 11 demo
kratz Tim Cavanaugh you've been
marinating in New Democrat ainia uh is
the era of the New Democrats with us is
it is it over what is this whole event
say about well I think it shows that it
exists that the the third way liberalism
exists now only as a vestige of hawkish
pneus on very on immigration and on
civil liberties and so forth in terms of
you know economics and on all the stuff
you just mentioned a marijuana and drug
war and so forth it's all gone I think
if you want a shadow convention you get
away till 2012 when Obama is running
again and has shown his true colors well
that's great we're going to go try to
look at some of those true colors inside
of mile high stadium on we'll see how
long it takes to wake and wait in the
line for reason TV I am Matt Welch thank
you